>>In 2002 we started off first
with nine middle schools, sort of--
we call them "Exploration Schools".
The fall of 2002 we went statewide,
every single seventh grader
in Maine had a laptop, every single
seventh grade classroom was a
wireless network, north, south,
east, west, rural, urban, statewide.
The next year, seventh and eighth.
The original design of the project
was to phase in a year each year
and go all the way to high school,
then budgets collapsed in 2003, 2004,
so the project essentially
stopped at middle school.
But the good news is it's still
going strong, it was renewed--
it was a four-year lease purchase,
the first project starting in '02,
so in '06 it was renewed by the
governor and the legislature
without my having to be
there to hound them about it,
they did it because it's worked.
And now I think about 20 of our 150
high schools have gone one to one
on their own, and then there's the
middle school project that's still
going on, seventh and eighth grade.
It's about 40,000 computers,
36,000 students, 4,000 teachers,
every classroom, and it's turned
out to be better than I thought.
We thought it was a good idea
back in 2002, in retrospect,
my thinking has gone
through sort of an evolution.
Good idea, then I realized
about the second year
in that it was really a radical idea
because of the changes in pedagogy
and the approach to
changes in education.
It was-- it's a different
kind of teaching and learning.
Now, as I'm looking around the
world and seeing what's happening
with globalization and
the kind of hollowing
out of the American economy,
I think it's a necessary idea.
It has empowered and created a lot
of the things that everybody's been
after in education for so long.
You can involve the parents,
if you do the technology
right, you engage the students.
If you ask teachers in Maine for
one word to describe the project,
it's generally "Engagement".
And any teacher will tell you
that if your students are engaged,
you can teach them anything.
If they're not engaged, you can be
Socrates and not teach them anything.
So engagement has been very powerful,
involving the students,
individualized learning.
I mean, this is a list of, you know,
what everybody's chasing in education
and have been for 100 years.
It really seems to be happening.
The laptops allow a
level of connection
and engagement in real stuff.
Searching out-- for example,
there's a program in Maine
where they use the laptops to analyze
water data or invasive species and,
you know, they're acting
like scientists.
And that's real and it has a
kind of intrinsic interest that--
particularly for kids that
aren't, you know, all that linear,
and I mean, if you think about it,
our education system is really
designed for certain kids.
And there are kids who
are very bright, but who--
that's just not the system
that they're gonna be--
they're not going to
shine in that system.
And the laptops are enabling kids
to do all kinds of different ways
to present what they're doing,
and that's one of the strengths.
It allows a kind of individualization
that is impossible if it's "Okay,
everybody write five paragraphs."
One of the things I've learned
from this is execution is
as important as vision.
You can have a great idea that makes
sense, and everybody says "Aha!"
But if it's not executed right,
if the network doesn't work,
if the computers crash
or if the teachers--
the biggest learning is if the
teachers aren't properly prepared
in a lot of professional development,
it just isn't going to work.
We're now trying to build
on what we've learned
and really take the professional
development to the next level,
that's the biggest part of it.
If you hand out the laptops and don't
do the professional development,
it's going to fail,
there's just no question.
It's not as expensive
as people think.
In Maine our project-- we can
put real, hard numbers on it,
it's nine million dollars a year
for every seventh and eighth grader
in the state, plus professional
development, tech support
and network, that's
the whole package.
And that represents about
four-tenths of one percent
of our annual school
budget in the state.
So we're talking about
one-half of one percent,
it's not a massive program, nine
million out of over two billion.
And when you look at it that
way, in terms of its impact
and potential impact, how long
do you have to think about that?
I mean, if I came to you at the
school board and said "I'm going
to give you something that's going
to significantly improve
writing scores",
which everybody's interested in, we
can talk about that in a few minutes,
but it's also going to
decrease discipline problems,
increase attendance and
provide your students
with true 21st century skills and
it's going to cost about the same
as your snowplowing budget, it seems
to me it's pretty hard to say "No".
>>What I tell people is don't
promise standardized test scores
because the tests don't
test what the laptops teach.
We're doing 1980s testing when
we want 21st century skills.
Solving problems, collaboration
and use of information,
that's what the laptops teach, but
the testing, the standardized testing
that we're doing is
testing, you know,
"When did Columbus discover
America" and, you know,
"What's eight times seventeen"?
And so there's a mismatch here,
and that's why I think maybe
at some point we'll be able to
design tests that really test,
you know, 21st century skills.
So that's why I tell people don't
promise standardized test scores
and you've just gotta
calm the politicians down,
because all they want is test
scores, and there's a heck
of a lot more than that at stake.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org